baptiste a passé toute la nuit sur ce
rond-point en compagnie d'une dizaine de
gilet jaune
mobilisés depuis l'aube il a fait le
choix de ne pas aller au travail pour
continuer à protester c'est un peu
compliqué parce que derrière moi j'ai ma
boîte d'intérim qui me demande ce que je
fais où je suis il va leur dire quand je
suis là la manifestation ça leur plaît
pas forcément donc bas derrière on
essaye de s'arranger qu'heureusement que
shawn est là où je suis ma responsable
qui me qui me remplace pour manifester
pour la bonne cause et puis bah on
essaye de faire comme honteux un état
d'esprit que partage karine cette maman
de quatre enfants est aujourd'hui en
reconversion professionnelle
elle organise son impôt du temps pour
gérer la vie de famille et la
mobilisation on s'arrange en famille on
se l'est fait garder les enfants les
malades cantine
et puis si on essaie d'être là au
maximum il faut qu'on soit mobilisé on
est solidaire et on lâchera rien faut
que ça se sache
les gilet jaune d'auxerre ont pu compter
sur la bienveillance des automobilistes
tout au long de la journée beaucoup
d'entre eux ont tenu à exprimer leur
solidarité on leur apportant de la
nourriture et des boissons et on les
aide comme on peut la nourriture du
fromage du pâté histoire qui puisse
tenir toute la journée pour leur montrer
qu'on est solidaire avec eux à 100% quoi
des gestes qui conforte les gilet jaune
de leur action une action pacifiste
comme ils tiennent à le rappeler on
déplore effectivement qui est des
incidents à droite à gauche
c'est ce qui est relativement en plus
c'est en ce moment très médiatisé mais
comme vous pouvez le voir ici ça se
passe une ambiance bon enfant il faut
que ça reste bon enfant pacifiste
toujours les gilet jaune de l'auxerrois
n'espère qu'une chose tenir dans la
durée jusqu'à samedi qui marquera une
nouvelle journée nationale de
mobilisation